aujourd'hui je vais tout balancer vous
avez été draguée autour de cette table
par guillaume jan three sides of heating
yeux ban doit pas cacher je sais que
maintenant voilà aujourd'hui tu as well
as d'autres destinations
mais que
non mais c'est vrai pour lui la coupe
est pleine ça y est tu peux pas sauter
de l'été dernier par guillaume jours
d'ailleurs il m'a invité aussi un macho
encore un match de foot et c'était sans
rien en échange
bien sûr juste essayer d'empêcher
gentiment aussi très pur l'un envers
l'autre alors je vais te dire c'est que
la pureté de l'eau
la nature la perte très fine tu as été
draguée là je vais je vais dévoiler tous
les gens qui ont dragué défini et vous
allez voir il ya des surprises non mais
les mecs c'est ça ma fait froid dans le
dos de près ou de loin j'ai vraiment
fait un panel globalcom sûr c'est comme
ça on normal oui je sais
non mais la fin du modèle global qui qui
va bien sinon meilleurs jeux qui tue
tibaoui acciona dame aveugle mais vous
s'il vous plaît aux
gens me draguer oui bien sûr jean-michel
invisible et tout le monde l'a vu
c'était plutôt ya à peu près deux ans
est très visible même à l'antenne donc
d'accord très bien voilà raymond vous a
dragué si si quand les réseaux sociaux
elle n'avait pas
essayé un peu quand on envoie la brigue
ou une auberge et sur le réseau selon
vraiment
c'est pas qu'on vous invite à faire le
match et
c'était bcr c'est trop long cours et
alors c'est très ses personnages
affectueux voilà un père aimant vous
habituer c'était pajama castaldi
s'était fait qu' il y avait un thé
lancement de quelque chose sont dorées
du tout
c'est et kasia des boues castadi arrêté
s'il accède par les ailes s'il vous
plaît delphine et j'ai dit je dirais ma
vérité sur castaldi d'accord et je
compte sur vous alors vous pouvez avec
ce même heat à leur
[Applaudissements]
cas c'est à dire c'est ce soir vous
dormez chez vous une coupe une couille
[Rires]
sa mort nous regarde non mais on peut
d'ores et déjà fermé la porte la rolls
at on évitera la
[Rires]
c'est il ya deux ans il ya presque
prescription a franchement non papa
confond vouer pour sa femme beaucoup
moins
alors c'était en laponie et c'est vrai
qu'on s'entendait bien benjamin c'est
vrai mais pas du tout
mais je parle pas de je parle on
s'entendait très bien regarde bien non
je peux pas la garder
[Rires]
mais un déclic après la laponie met
alors à paniquer non la laponie la fin
du jeu vous faire sortir il a maintenant
il ne me regardent plus mais
effectivement on laponie on s'entendait
bien on se taquinait bien même non non
la fois de plus il m'a volé un chausson
est aussi en cours je lui ai couru après
et après des alouettes vraiment la forêt
et a coupé mon jeu c'est très bien je
vais toucher les choses au service et
dans ses mangas étaient en est et taquin
on était très marrante certain guerre
peu ça sera oui mais non mais voilà je
vois quand on côtoie le chausson c'est
pas de la drague si on coupe à mes
chaussons tous les jours mais
debout et donc ensuite c'est la fameuse
nuit en question avait dit
la vidéo mais je vous envoie une grande
chance il doit une pub le reste avec
métro alors il n'y a rien de grave mais
pour beaucoup comme un muscle et moi
s'il vous plaît arrêter alors à jamais
est ce que vous avez en prévision un
prochain mariage
[Rires]
cette nuit c'est donc vous avez dormi
ensemble alors je vois le duel à 4h joue
appel de fonds devrait donc la durée
donc racisées toujours éveillé
c'est vrai il devait être 19h mais
faisait vraiment bien nuit et donc vous
avez dit quand on ferait une soirée plus
ou moins pyjama tous ensemble moi je
regrette tout seul voilà ce qui
d'ailleurs ne s'est jamais fait en voilà
alors et alors vous avez dit il faut que
delphine parce qu'elle manque de
chambres à dormir chez benjamin et
c'était pour une séquence télé en plus
ce que j'ai fait puisque je suis très
bon élève et que je veux j'ai découvert
des gens c'est pas du tout ça c'est
continue à tirer au sort qui dorment
avec oui
vous êtes encore là parce que vous êtes
arrivé après et moi j'ai pas ma chambre
et alors on a 10 bat delphine helle de
rock qui pour la séquence télé bim bim
elle arrive dans une chambre ce que j'ai
fait du coup je suis arrivé dans la
chambre et et voilà et donc y avait il y
avait deux il y avait deux lits y avait
2 et via un canal voilà et donc du coup
bah moi je suis dans ma chambre j'ai des
coups tirés il a dit qu'il fallait aller
dans la chambre
et j'ai dit c'est cool parce qu'en plus
on pourra faire connaissance parce que
je pensais qu'ils avaient il y avait
alors il y avait une amitié et delphine
en plus elle est très garçon manqué
alors là d'un poêle ou encore une photo
où elle dormait avec un pot telle
qu'elle dort avec des potes non mais il
avait réveillé pas de mal mais non merci
s'il n'ya pas de mal mais gaza du coup
son pote
et donc l'embellie est donc très longue
liste est donc allé s'est endormi et
castaldi s'est endormi je suis parti et
depuis il ne me parle plus rejoué après
je lui dirai pourquoi tu me parles plus
oui mais ma femme elle a appris un truc
je sais pas quoi de laponie et du coup
elle veut plus que je te parle la langue
c'est ça
oui
anosy sommes voilà
ça tire à balle mais voilà sa réponse
est venue du bâton et copines
la bonne foi ne veut plus vous parlait à
nelly n'est pas du tout aisée à résoudre
l'énigme n'est elle a eu vent d'une
histoire en laponie
boladé marre de cette histoire je veux
lundi d'une seule et unique personne de
qui il est en colère qui çà et là ce
soir kenny rogers texan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un trotteur
auteur - chéri comme ça qu'on doit bien
assez bien rendue à regarder c'est mon
roger damour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui à huy ah oui
sa maman routeur bonsoir à tous sheridan
surprise fondatrice est là mais oui mais
j'ai presque les larmes étaient venus
pour vous
simon rogers bataille alors des coups
alors voiture dans la mare que tout le
monde branche tama fouet alors je sais
que tu as une grande confiance en elle
et c'est ça qui est beau et c'est vrai
que tu peux avoir confiance en delphine
je peux te dire j'ai confiance mais ça
n'empêche pas le contrôle ah oui c'est
ça ouais donc dans ma lointaine alsace
j'ai les oreilles qui sifflent intérêts
donc il ya des moments franchement
j'entends
ce soir que delphine est en couple
[Rires]
est-ce qu'on peut commencer
bien sûr j'avais vu des photos sur un je
pensais que c'était un ami de son père
on
dira alors est-ce qu'on peut commencer
bien sûr lui qui me déçoit le plus c'est
bon pas les effets qu est un pays il est
d'origine d'alsace y est ils invitent
delphine à manger chaque fois tact et
petit sms
n'aurait-on mexique
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolée c'était mon frère
ils s'entendent très bien chaque fois
oui mais oui je les échecs de place dans
la voiture
non mais des fois je suis très très très
bon après je suis qui m'a pas déçu du
tout c'est mathieu à
[Rires]
bâle et et puis l'histoire de la peau ni
même alors que jamais benjamin
franchement m'a déçu quand je suis
arrivé ici à trois ans avec delphine
c'est la première personne connue avec
qui j'ai fait un selphy une photo là
c'est une célébrité et là ils l'ont bois
ils envoient des messages tout ça aulas
j'ai dit à delphine del si tu peux pas
avoir un truc avec ce mec on a ces
dettes c'est bon
[Rires]
à quoi bon
ça pouvait pas gaz et avec
des gaz et un bar je voulais vous dites
pourquoi me delphine en plus on attire
aussi on attend et on s'est retrouvé
dans la chambre avec moi j'ai cassé la
baraque à ses dires problèmes de gaz le
savons pas si c'est vrai
c'est vrai défi surtout l'accueil
température en laponie tout ce qui avait
de froid dehors était chaud à
l'intérieur
donc voilà je voudrais dire que rogers
et la soif ferrari et il prend ça
vraiment avec le soutien sur j'aime
vraiment ce n'est que c'est mon job je
voulais tout réussir et devenir l'étoile
à sourire si une guinguette c'est une
langue est maintenant on fait plus de
blé a beau nous on n'a fait qu'un jet
donc n'allez pas au sunshine
[Applaudissements]
voilà